alors je suis pour la prudence donc s'il
le faut oui en effet je serais pour 1/3
des profils mans malheureusement pour
les commerces c'est dramatique mais il
est préférable quand même de de
préserver la santé des gens c'est pour
le bien public on va dire y'a pas de
soucis mais bon là les personnes en fait
tout autour de nous elles en ont marre
raisonnons marre de ça dans d'autres
pays c'est mieux gérer et je pense que
le gouvernement devrait revoir un peu
ses priorités faso coronavirus
psychologiquement ça commence à être dur
déjà là le couvre-feu 18 heures c'est un
peu violent troisième confinement déjà
le deuxième il m'a un peu abattu moi
donc
donc non pas de troisième confinement on
a pu travailler je travaille plus je
fais plus rien donc ça ferait du bien
que ça commence par un peu j'avais
justement chercher de l'aide
tellement c'est le bordel je m'en
rendais pas compte je pense que j'étais
un peu trop égoïste je pensais que ça
peut toucher que moi mais apparemment et
je crois que ça fait pas mal de monde en
partie ma tranche d'âge ce que j'ai
confiance en l'avenir mais
mais là dans le chai inquiet pour le
présent c'est déjà énorme
autant faire comme lui premier parce que
le deuxième pour ceux qui travaillent
nous ça change rien les gens ils
continuent à sortir la seule fois qu'on
a bien vu les chiffres sur le premier
confinement ça réduit drastiquement les
chiffres alors que le deuxième a repris
quoi par exemple cet été-là n'a
quasiment pas de cas parce qu'on sortait
du premier confinement et en était un
on était tous chez nous d'ailleurs choix
de la france analyse seul pays qui
marche comme ça en angleterre c'est
confinement total donc comme le premier
ou personnes sortent de chez lui après
ils ont des chiffres qui sont quand même
plus élevé que les autres mais moi je
pense que si c'est nécessaire autant
confinés comme le premier camp à part
vous dire que je sais plus quoi penser
parce que j'ai l'impression que donne
l'état pour quoi qu'ils fassent prend
pas forcément les bonnes décisions ou
donne la pression ne pas prendre les
bonnes décisions parce que je suis pas à
leur place je sais pas quoi vous dire je
suis juste consterné moi j'ai un
conjoint qui est dans la restauration et
vous comprenez que la situation devient
compliquée je suis jeune maman enfin on
a l'impression qu'on oublie plein de
secteurs
il ya des gens qui souffrent et ça en
l'oubli et il ya un moment donné
enfin oui un virus oui il faut faire
attention mais des gens vont crever de
faim de compliqué je pense après deux
confinement déjà vécu ça va
ça va être dur mais je pense qu'il faut
le faire quand on pourrait voir comment
le le conseil scientifique préconise
mais moi je pense qu'il faut suivre
l'avis des scientifiques en fait si le
confinement est court et pris
suffisamment tôt ça peut être bénéfique
oui ça c'est chiant c'est sûr mais ça
peut être bénéfique pour tout le monde
le stade et j'ai tellement entendu de
choses du gouvernement je n'en sais rien
si ça peut aider oui s'il ya si vraiment
c'est nécessaire pour le faire oui je
préfère qu'il y en a un bon une fois
pour toutes
voilà pour en finir avec ça un
confinement qui servent à quelque chose
pas des petites mesures confinement de
15 jours du saas ans on a vu la preuve
ça ne sert à rien